в нас нічого не залишилось Ой я не хочу
це вспоминати Мені дуже тяжко Ну не було
ще такої допомоги особливої тому ходили
брали десь цеглу розбиту які як кажуть
повикидали і будували літо Ніхто нічого
і на копійку не зробив і ось осінь
пройшла ось зима вже закидала снігом і
ніхто нічого Це село ягідне на
Чернігівщині місце воєнних злочинів
російських загарбників що шокували весь
світ сніг ховає решт чорного попелища
яке лишилося на місці майже усіх
тутишніх хат у березні 2022го росіяни
спалили тут понад 170 будинків протягом
28 днів окупації жителі села змушені
були сидіти в полоні у підвалі місцевої
школи Ось у цій кімнаті було прожли 170
чоловік 39 дітей люди помирали то що не
хватало повітря Не було чим дихати
задихалися їсти не хватало 11 Лів села
померли прямо тут у підвалі розповідає
свідок подій шкільний сторож Іван
росіяни не дозволяли поховати тіла Тож
вони тижнями лежали поруч із живими коли
нас визволили можна сказати що ми другий
раз родилися на
світ Надії ні в кого не було що хтось
отсюда вийде живим коли ми вийшли з
віцередак там нічого в селі село
повністю було розбите будинок пані
Тамари за кілька сотень метрів від школи
росіяни спалили перед тим як відступити
села відтак жінці Довелося ще кілька
тижнів ночувати у тому ж підвалі де
тількино пережила полон Ну я вийшла бачу
горить ну ну що ну що я сделаю я ж кажу
що оцей якби орки пустили спеціально
робили щоб воно горіло щоб воно
других де Де
взривали це в мене ванна була там двері
були в кухню це тут було все в мене вира
веранда отоплювалася оце в мене хата
грубку зробив в том году кум зробив
грубку бачите ось У мене ліжко зараз
жінка живе в сараї його до війни
облаштував зять якого росіяни застрелили
Під час окупації журнал сечас я вам
покажу ось наш підвал Ось я ось я сиджу
Ось ось оце труби йдуть ось речі висіли
тоді тут страховище було історія
окупації села ягідне привернула увагу
міжнародних благодійників та політиків
зокрема уряд Латвії виділив кошти на
відбудову даху і стін десятків місцевих
хат серед них і Пані Тамари однак коштів
вистачило не на все тому жити вдома
пенсіонерка все ще не може лотвіці знову
ж приїжджав тут президент там зустріч
була нас ту з соседкою не пустили нас
сюди не пустили щоб ми щось
говорили вони Тоді пішли в підвал
сходили і сіли машинами і поїхали літо
Ніхто нічого і на копійку не зробив і
ось осінь пройшла ось зима уже закидала
снігом і ніхто нічого вони можуть отак
прийти попитати і уйти і все із концами
Була надія ну короше наші наша комісія
отг сказала що вам нема А чого нема Все
оформили бумаги всі
Ну нема каже пенсіонер Михайло
розповідає Що не раз звертався по
допомого і до місцевої влади і до членів
міжнародних делегацій які приїздили у
ягідне поки ті нарешті не відгукнулися і
не встановили нові вікна у його хату
інші жителі села зіткнулися з подібним
досвідом клала вчилася цеглу класти самі
будували своїми руками тому що ну не
було ще такої допомоги особливої тому
ходили брали десь цеглу розбиту які як
кажуть повикидали і будували куча битої
цегли от вона он там ще лежить снігом
прики прикидана оце всім оце начинаєш
розказувати в мене вже тіпає всю оцього
всього Ольга каже якби не волонтери
довелося б і другу зиму ночувати в
гаражі
стіни криша вікна двері ну всі ці роботи
які вони могли по плану робити от вони
зробили завезли нам дров щоб ми
перезамували щоб ми не замерзли це їм
велика дяка в ягідному ми зробили більше
80 будинків наша ініціатива вона дуже
потрібна бо в найближчі 10 років Україні
потрібно 1,5 млн Будівельників
сподіваємося що підхопиться ініціатива і
далі буде ро
робитися попри сніг у ягідному нині
ведуться будівельні роботи 10 хат
відбудовують підрядники яких найняла
держава на них Тут чекали з квітня саме
тоді село долучили до урядової програми
відновлення це експериментальний проект
комплексний відбудови шести українських
сіл І містечок що найбільше постраждали
від дій російських окупантів кошторис
проєкту у ягідному склали на 400 млн грн
на ці кошти планувалося відновити
інфраструктуру села та більшість
згорілих осель
118 про нас почув весь світ і напевно
Саме через це ми попали в оцю урядову
програму обіцяли що проект завершиться в
цьому році Ну по в частині приватних
будинків житлових так трапилось Що вони
у нас почали роботу десь два тижні назад
тільки за час затримки понад 80 будинків
із тих які планувала відновити держава
вже відбудували волонтери залишилися
лише утеплювальні роботи і покрівля
будівельники не розуміють Чому влада
дала добро на початок робіт лише тепер
узимку фарбування наносити фактуру
це неможливо тому що ну це буде брак
просто брак все Чого так пізно що в
зимку чого не раніше ну дивно звісно
краще конечно коли тепло а ну сказали що
будемо робити взимку то що нам будемо
робити комплексна відбудова затягнулася
через бюрократичні процедури пояснюють у
службі відновлення і розвитку
інфраструктури у Чернігівській області
Ось ця
Ось бумажна волокіта так би мовити Ну і
плюс то що це перший такий проект і ми
так Ну першопрохідці у цьому більшість
вже договорів заключено ще частина
залишається невизна у невизначеному
стані оскільки нема там чи документів
правильно оформлених чи власників немає
тут ще одна перепона для завершення
комплексної відбудови від держави брак
фінансування ягідному потрібно ще 216
млн грн та чи будуть ці кошти наразі
невідомо кажуть у міністерстві
відновлення якщо буде ситуація знову ж
таки там погіршення з фронтом і так далі
то і ті Кошти які планувалися мають піти
на оборону тобто тут сумнівів нема
фактично бюджет наступного року він не
має видатків на відновлення ми
фокусуємося на обороні це так і має бути
це правильно логічно розраховуємо на
допомогу партнерів пов'язано з
відновлення це ми купили котла за свій
рахунок ми включилися якими силами які
ми могли от А зараз ми тоже не чекаємо
ми ми зробили електрику ми ми провели
воду ми провели Кана
Ольга Чию хату в ягідному частково
відновили волонтери каже є де зимувати і
вже добре в нас нічого не залишилось
отак як ми були у грязній одежі у
підвалі Отак ми прийшли і побачили це
все розбите в нас появилась надія що і
Ми колись возродимося із пепла Надія в
нас щоб була перемога і щоб був мир
оцього монстра
російського больного на голову щоб його
загнали в угол і знищили отам щоб оці
оця вся шка ушла на свої землі не
трогала нас пам'ять про окупацію та
знищення ягідного жителі та місцева
Влада хочуть зробити частиною відбудови
у планах на місці школи із сумнозвісним
підвалом зробити музеймеморіал кожну
деталь каже сторож Іван тут хочуть
зробити експонатом
х Ось такі стаканчики це на двоїх
неповний стаканчик полосі щоб на суки
поїсти було без хліба хотіли б щоб світ
побачив що воно за нація така рашисти що
воно за
[музика]
люди